after a steak and eggs breakfast 77 year
old John Glenn and the others suited up
and went to the pad for final boarding
of course so much of the sky-high
publicity and history here today is that
Senator Glenn is Speck seem to be the
oldest person ever in space 36 years
after his and America's first trip to
orbit that was CBS News in 1998 as
Senator John Glenn flew aboard the space
shuttle Discovery at the time Glenn
returned to orbit former NASA astronaut
scott Parazynski was his personal
physician dr. Burzynski has traveled
more than 23 million miles in space over
his 17-year career he's flown five
missions and conducted seven spacewalks
he's also the only person to fly in
space and reach the summit of Mount
Everest separate occasions in his new
memoir he offers an inside look at his
life as an astronaut doctor the book is
called the sky below a true story of
summits space and speed dr. Pierzynski
welcome to the table thank you so much
for having me it's a real thrill to be
here so you performed one of the most
dangerous spacewalks to date tell us
about that it was my best day on the job
ever but also pretty high pucker factor
moment I guess not okay we had to go out
and repair a live solar panel and it was
one of these situations where we had to
accept a little bit higher risk because
the rewards were were that important it
was on my last mission sts-1 20 and we
had installed the new solar array truss
out of the very tip of the space station
and as it was being commanded to unfurl
it began to rip apart and so this was
basically a limp noodle out there that
needed to either be addressed in some
way or we'd have to go out and throw
away a billion dollar national asset so
what was the risk to you well
electrocution so any direct contact
between the metal parts of my spacesuit
and the panel sensibly could cause a
really bad day on orbit Forrest what did
you do well so an incredible team of
people in in Houston and around the
country came up with a brilliant plan
within 72 hours to basically stitch
together this solar panel out at the
very tip of the space station further
than we'd ever gone before so it was
really a Hail Mary play and
just you know certainly in a Apollo 13
style so that should be enough for any
man or woman you also had to go climb
Mount Everest why didn't have to but I
was compelled to it
yeah I've been climbing since I was
about 15 years old and just the
challenge of going to the world's
highest peak I had seen it from orbit
I'm and I took this beautiful photograph
looking straight down on the summit of
Mount Everest and I conjured up in my
mind what would it look like to actually
have my boot prints down there on that
on that beautiful summit and so many
years later on my second attempt I was
able to to top out in the um talk about
the the toll that climbing Mount Everest
and space travel takes on the body there
are many challenges yeah actually I
think my repeated exposures to space
actually set me up for a back injury
which unfortunately led to a ruptured
disc on Mount Everest in 2008 but as we
go up into space we actually grow I I'm
six-three here on earth when I don't
slouch but up in space I'm about six
five and a half and it's it's fantastic
I wish I could hold on to that height
when I come back to earth but what
happened you shrink right back shrink
back right right back down and those
repeated cycles probably led to a
weakening of my spine and then on on
Mount Everest in 2008 I ruptured a disc
and had to limp on down so what else are
we finding about the impact on your body
of being in space well one of the big
challenges is our vision is impacted so
a lot of our long duration astronauts
are coming back with permanent changes
to their vision and so the concern is if
if we send crews to Mars for two or
three year mission will they have you
know functional vision by the time they
get there by the time they come back to
earth
John Atlin good yes in a limited time
talk about John Glenn and going up with
him and what it was like one of the
greatest Americans of our time was the
greatest honor of my life to be in his
presence and to call him a friend and
crew mate I think the world of him you
he was an incredible crew mate he added
to our knowledge of science I I miss him
dearly Oh is there any reason for him
not to go
I can't think of a single one physically
he was up to he was 77 at the time in
top physical condition of course
brilliant man you know
shark sharpest attack until his dying
day 77 and you talk about the stress
that space travel and mountain climbing
has had on your body what did you see
after he came back well he had a little
bit of an issue with balance so you know
our our or neurovestibular system the
the inner ear gives us our balance here
on earth but up in space without gravity
our eyes become our primary sensors so
that's how we tell which is what word
that the ceiling and the floor is and so
coming back at actually the reverse
happens and we have to readjust the
earthís one gravity and so he had he had
wobbly legs for a day or two after and
landing not uncommon actually for our
long duration astronauts who spend six
months in war so let's see what can we
figure out for you to do next yeah I
have a tech startup and I'm an author
now so I'm really thrilled to share this
book with the world that's not the same
kind of risk well you know it's
interesting so you you kind of bury your
soul in a book and so it's actually
quite a challenge to put it all on paper
but I'm really proud of the way the
story that we're able to tell with my
collaborative writer Susie Florrie
and it's you know the pathway to success
is nonlinear and you have to accept some
failures along the way and so I've had
failures I've had some close calls you
know with my health is as well and so
you know the by setting goals and and
being resolute in in achieving them you
know wonderful things can happen thank
you for coming vice thank you doctor
Parazynski right the sky below goes on
sale tomorrow you can hear more of CBS
this morning on our podcast though fine
extended interviews and podcast
originals on iTunes and Apple's podcast
at